[Musique]
évidemment je suis je suis tout ça dit
ah oui j'allais voir impossible patent
vraiment pas le temps immédiatement j'ai
déjà réservé ma place faut dire que
c'est un des succès au box-office donc
et vidéos alors maintenant ça non là bas
il va de l'avant mais avant même d'abord
bonne l'arrière lors quand tu t'appelles
comment michael fried m'appelle mois
plus de la dissiper au cours actuel pour
eux et moi c'est uche un quinté comme tu
es là et la meute et ben c'est pas la
honte et kt et vous c'est était pas là
t'es pas là où c'était un terrain avec
jef touche personnelle sur le schuss
j'ai 2 1 j'ai gagné un euro oui la
roulette j'ai gagné un numéro fétiche du
mont st clément jouer aux courses j'ai
gagné à un moment un peu pas beaucoup
des petites sommes j'ai arrêté je peux
perdre n'y crois pas ma première
élection c'est je prends le ticket
photographie mille fois une petite
pochette plastique
woods a gagné et je le colle à mal est
comme ça au moins je ne pourrais pas le
perdre très content quoi s'il gagne au
loto
je crée l'entreprise jean bruce des gens
et j'envoie des chômeurs je souhaite un
jour pour moi ma mère ça pourra faire
des allers-retours jusque là en tunisie
en ce moment en avoir fait un bisou au
plan européen
je vais faire les magasins j'achète une
maison à ma mère et je pars en vacances
pour les bayonnais après que le suédois
en jour cela provoque pas bien falloir
en sortant de sa zone de confort et une
blague sur l'auto qui est assez drôle
moi même qui tous les jours dit à l'afp
mois gagne au loto comme ça pendant des
années et un jour le ciel s'ouvre à dieu
car qui dit et moi même si tu veux
gagner
joe bon dépoter
[Musique]
oui bien sûr plus chanceux déjà ben ali
est une chance mais j'en ai rencontré et
c'en est une autre
ouais pas très grand chose c'est bon je
capable avec vous mais je me considère
très chanceuse parce que tout ce qui
arrive dans ma vie c'était pas prévu
tout et freestyle
oui je suis chanceux je suis en bonne
santé ma famille mais aussi donc je
pense que c'est le plus important
non alors moi je suis pas chanceux je
suis le parfait loser mais ça me va très
bien comme ça
[Musique]